[Music]
you the lamp pyrite or civil war and
the finish or the
which is an old black hair population and so
crashed with the got
grade skewers have those little ones and Jozef
nike tee nike to patient
I probably love the monastery 1,000
percent increase
from this ratio numbers week love this
critical to have loco motion begins
eintes in the following pak100 versus
it's important for eyes
shore name bus christ or something van
waste in the chain will be six at home
cancellation
so growing number of my life or global
or what can be done in many areas
Africa
eefje headset is a good shape
potential is the for the and grandmothers who
recover and the end of the day you can't
have national park has this new one
ownership by the nation and national
park shabby and practice is the pride and
joy of a nation and just become who you win
princes
locally in Mozambique and full
singing pupation
mozambique insight is and this helps
achieve this in future
[Music]